Joyeux Noël Vivien.
Merci, c’est quoi?
Ouvre.
Du papier cadeau!
T’es fou fallait pas.
Si tu veux, je le prend.
Non non non, je le garde.
C'est pour toi.
T’es dingue.
Merci ! C’est quoi ?
Bah devine.
C’est quand même pas un pull?
-Non.
C’est une écharpe?
-Non
C’est une salopette?
C’est un plaid?
-Non
Une sortie de Bain?
Un édredon?
-Non
Un édredon douillet?
David Douillet?
-Non
C’est un Kiwi?
C’est un pont?
-Non
C’est un canapé?
C’est une Loutre?
-Non
C’est un coussin?
C’est un rideau?
-Non
C’est une planche?
Une petite planche?
-Non
Un Ukulélé?
Une table?
-Non, Non / HEIN HEIN
Le duplicata de mon acte de naissance plié en deux?
-Non
Une autre table?
Du beurre?
-Non
De la poudre?
Un plis?
-Non
Le «T» de Prospectus?
La station spatiale internationale?
-Non
Un canyon?
-Oui !
C’est vrai?
-Non
Une huitre?
Du Jambon
-Non
Un gouvernement?
Ablnemulos pas
Une aptitude?
-Non
Un clu.clu.club de Go.Golf?
Une enclave?
-Non
Une clé de bras?
Une grenouille?
-Non
La photo de 14 randonneurs
disparus mystérieusement dans un massif quelconque? -Non
Riri
-Non
Fifi
Du sable?
-Non
Du sable fin?
La fin de «Raging Bulls»
-Non
Le loup?
-…
Non
Un diamètre?
-Non
Un type d’huile?
Un point Ninja?
-Non
Une brûlure au second degré?
-Miaou
Au premier?
-Non
Un parachute doré?
Une départementale?
Du calcium?
Une bougie de mobylette?
Son système immunitaire
Une division Euclidienne?
C’est…..un…..logiciel…
...de montage…
...vidéo…
OUI!